und fest zu berlin gehörte eigentlich
auch immer der flughafen berlin tegel
der steht jetzt aber schneller vor dem
aus als geplant eigentlich sollte der
airport noch in betrieb bleiben bis der
neue br ende oktober eröffnet doch nun
sind cola bedingt die fluggastzahlen
eingebrochen
das hat bund und länder dazu bewogen die
schließung für den 15
juni anzukündigen vorübergehen wie es
heißt allerdings genau dann wenn der
reiseverkehr sich normalisieren sollte
eigentlich wieder und wie zu beginn der
sendung angekündigt wir sprechen darüber
mit meinem kollegen michael sauerbier
das klingt alles nicht so richtig
überlegt was wir da von bund und länder
hören tegel also demnächst zu was
passiert denn eigentlich wenn kohler
sich jetzt doch stärker abschwächt und
man doch wieder mehr reist im sommer
oder tja wie könnte es anders sein sich
br vielleicht noch weiter verschiebt ja
jetzt schon guten tag erstmal aus titel
ist genau diesem fall das vielleicht
dann doch mit der lockerung von
reisebeschränkungen mit einer
zunehmenden schlug lust mehr leute
fliegen sollten hat sich der flughafen
eine hintertür ausgehalten
flughafenchefs engelberg wird gedacht
hat zunächst eine temporäre schließung
des flughafen tegels für zwei monate
beantragt das heißt bis mitte august
bis dahin sollte gesamte berliner
flugverkehr über schönefeld abgewickelt
werden wohlgemerkt noch nicht über den
neuen br zu kaufen
der wird erst am 31 oktober eröffnet
sondern über den alten ddr regierungs
flughafen schönefeld der bis zu elf
millionen passagiere verkraftet tegel
kämen noch mal mit 24 millionen
passagieren dazu also sollte die
reiselust steigen kann
tegel noch einmal geöffnet werden
allerdings gibt es an absolute
schlussdatum nämlich den acht november
eine woche nach der eröffnung des br zu
gast
immer wieder spannend was da so
entschieden wird michael sauerbier ganz
herzlichen dank für diese zusätzlichen
informationen zur vorübergehenden
schließung von tegel vom flughafen tegel
ab dem 15 juni